in a previous video we talked about how
you can represent a system of equations
as essentially a matrix equation so for
example here i have two equations with
two unknowns x y well let's just assume
that we know what a b p c d and q r and
you can represent this type of system as
a matrix vector equation like this where
the coefficients on the x's are this
first column coefficients on the y's are
the second column and then we see our
unknown variables what we would want to
solve for maybe
as this vector here so you could do that
as the unknown two-dimensional vector
and then we know when we either think
about it as a transformation on this
unknown vector we get this known vector
we get the vector pq or you could think
about it as matrix multiplication when
you multiply this vector by this matrix
you get this pq vector and in other
videos we also talked about this idea of
inverses
so for example if we call this right
over here matrix a
you can imagine that what we're seeing
here is matrix a
times the vector
x y
i'll just write it like that is equal to
the vector
pq i'll just stick to one color for
convenience right now
and we talked about this idea that if
you have an inverse of a matrix times
the matrix it's going to give you the
identity matrix so one idea for trying
to quote solve this
matrix vector equation is what if we
multiplied both sides on the left by the
inverse of a
so if i had a inverse here and if i
multiplied by a inverse here what would
happen
well assuming a inverse exists and
that's actually going to be the focus of
this video if a inverse exists then this
right over here is just going to become
the identity matrix so that's just the
matrix that if i try to transform
anything or if i multiply anything by it
it's just going to give us that thing
that we had before in the 2 by 2
scenario the identity matrix it looks
looks like that
and then on the right hand side we'll be
multiplying a 2 by 2 matrix times the
vector pq
and so on the left hand side essentially
the identity matrix times x y is just
going to give us
x y and on the right hand side we would
know what that equals to so that would
essentially solve this system when it is
represented that way
but this gives us a clue about thinking
when is it solvable because when it's
solvable you're going to have a
situation where you do have an inverse
here and when it's not solvable you're
going to have a situation where there is
no inverse here where this matrix a does
not have an inverse
so when we go back to what we've learned
in previous algebra classes about
solving systems of equations we know
there's two scenarios where we get
either no solutions or an infinite
number of solutions let me draw a little
coordinate axis here we know if the
lines have different slopes so one line
looks like this and then the other line
it could look like anything as long as
it has a different slope they are going
to intersect at exactly one point two
lines with different slopes are going to
intersect intersect in exactly one point
the situation which you have no
solutions is if they are the same
slope
so parallel lines like this would not
intersect
another weird situation that you get
when you solve systems is they have the
same slope but they're the same line
so that would be something like this
there would not be a unique x y there
would actually be an infinite x y
that would satisfy the equation so those
are both situations where we're not
finding a nice clean unique solution to
our system and if we think about the
matrix world where we're not going to
find an inverse of a that when we
multiply it times pq it gives us a nice
clean solution in either of those
scenarios where we the two equations
have the same slope now let's think
about what do we know about a b c d when
we have the same slope so if we were to
try to put this top equation into slope
intercept form what would that look like
well let's see we can subtract ax from
both sides so you could have something
like this b y is equal to p
minus
ax i just subtract ax from both sides
and then if you divide both sides by b
you get y is equal to p over b minus a
over b x and so you can see in this
first equation our slope is negative a
over b now what about the second
equation well by the same logic if you
do the same thing you subtract c x from
both sides and then divide by d
you're going to get y is equal to q
over d
minus c
over d
x
and so we see the slope here is negative
c over d
so these strange scenarios not strange
but these scenarios where you don't get
a nice clean unique solution are the
ones where these slopes are equivalent
to each other so we're talking about the
scenario in which negative a over b is
equal to negative c
over d
now to make a little bit of sense of
that let's say we multiply both sides of
this equation by negative bd to get rid
of these things out of the denominator
so let me do that and i'm multiplying by
a negative to get rid of the negatives
negative b d
so on the left hand side the b
cancels with the b negative times a
negative is a positive we're going to
get a d
and on the right hand side negatives
cancel out d goes away and then you have
c
b or another way to think about it is a
d
minus c b is going to be equal to zero
when ad minus cb is equal to zero this
system of equations does not have a
unique solution
now things bells might be rigging in
your head right now because a d so
that's a times d
minus
c
times b
minus c times b
that's the determinant of this matrix a
here so this is going to be true only in
a situation if and only if the
determinant of our matrix a is equal to
zero so just like that we have a pretty
neat clue about when you're not going to
see a nice neat solution to systems of
equations represented as a matrix vector
equation like this you're not going to
have a nice clean unique solution when
the determinant of your matrix a is
equal to 0
and since you're not going to have a
nice clean solution you must not be able
to find an inverse here because if you
had an inverse you could just multiply
it so this is a situation where this is
only going to be true and i haven't
proven it rigorously but hopefully it
gives you a little bit of a
justification this is a situation where
a inverse doesn't
exist
so there's a lot that's interesting here
in a previous video we thought about a
matrix a and we thought about it as a
transformation and how its determinant
tells us how we are scaling areas but if
it's determinant to zero that means
you're taking things that have
two-dimensional area and you're scaling
them down to having zero area it'd be
very hard to go the other way around
which is what
a inverse transformation matrix would do
here we're getting the same result not
viewing matrix a as a transformation but
viewing it as a representation of a
system of linear equations like this but
once again we got the same idea that if
the determinant of a is equal to zero
you're not going to get a nice clean
solution here and so the inverse does
not exist